members and ladies and gentlemen I'm
going to go through the emergency
evacuation announcement now there are no
planned fire drills so if the alarm goes
off please leave the building in an
orderly fashion through the nearest fire
exit please use the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the store room adjacent to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance to
the building please pleas do not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by Council staff please note that the
meeting will be live streamed please
switch off mobile phones or turn them to
silent please note that the toilet and
handwashing facilities are in the 4year
area members I would like to remind you
that if you wish to use the toilet and
handwashing Facilities you may excuse
yourself from the meeting without the
requirement to raise your hand at your
own
discretion members of the public there
is drinking water available near the
main doors into the Hall while you can
of course film or take photographs
during this meeting please note that
this should be done without disruption
to the meeting and can only be done from
seats that have been reserved for this
purpose can I please therefore ask you
to raise your hand clearly in the air if
you wish to take photographs or film
this
evening thank
you members please be upstanding to
receive the chairman Reverend Kim lepley
and the chief executive Jonathan
Stevenson thank
you
members thank you can I ask Reverend Kim
lley if she would just lead us in
proceeding before the
meeting please do be
[Music]
seated as always it's a great privilege
to be here to open your meeting uh with
prayer this morning uh with this evening
so if you wouldn't mind joining me then
let us
pray almighty God we bring before you
the agenda for tonight's meeting that we
who have been entrusted with the
responsibility to govern and make
decisions for those who have elected us
that we be guided by the best of motives
and with the interests of all for the
benefit of
all give all our counselors clear minds
and the desire to hear all points of
view including those who may be opposed
to our to their own and an openness of
respectful
debate make them gracious and courteous
to friend and opponent alike with a
sense of working together for this
district and the areas that they
represent by each of our district
councelors at the same time Lord we
commend for your blessing the work of
all the the employees of Rochford
District Council who maintain Implement
and make possible the words that are
debated discussed and formed into
policy this we ask in Jesus name
amen if you know the words and would
like to I invite you now to join me in
saying the word the the prayer that
Jesus taught us the words of the family
prayer Our Father which art in heaven
Hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done on Earth as it is in
heaven give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses as we
forgive those that trespass against us
and lead us not into temptation but
Deliver Us from Evil for thine is the
kingdom the power and and the glory
forever and ever
amen so may God infold you in love fill
you with peace and Lead You In Hope and
the blessing of God Almighty the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit be with you
all and all whom you love this night and
forever more
amen so I hope you have a really good
meeting and if you didn't have pancakes
before you came out that they'll be
waiting for you when you get home God
bless
you would you want to stay you're
welcome to stay I thought you might
thank you very much thank
you
evening members well welcome to the
Rochford District council's Four council
meeting I mean it's already been spok to
you but if you could uh please when
voting please sh hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands for then and against
recommendations and then for
staining given the size of this room and
the numbers of us present can I please
ask that you put your hand up clearly
high in the air so that it can be easily
seen by all and leave it up until I ask
you to lower it the normal rules of
debate apply no member should speak for
more than five minutes and can I ask you
you to not repeat anything previously
said although those indicating to speak
will be given an opportunity to speak
once thank you we now move on to agenda
item one apologies for
absence we have an apology for absence
from councelor Elliot Mason are there
any
others
counc councelor Daniel
FD anyone
else thank you item agenda agenda item
two the minutes h of the meeting held on
the 14th of December please can I ask
members are you happy me for me to sign
these meetings they're
minuts yes thank you item three
Declarations of in interest are there
any Declarations of
Interest CC step
time thank you chairman uh as a member
of Barling Parish Council which will
become relevant later on in the meeting
thank you any
others thank you item four announcements
for myself or the head of pay service
there are no
announcements but I will say that we the
next item is item five is from the youth
workers the youth Council can I just say
that um we're going to invite them to do
a short presentation which will be on
the board over here I'm looking forward
to it you're very welcome to this
meeting our youth should be involved in
our decision making and you're very
welcome but at the end of it if you have
any questions please indicate in the
usual manner
and I'll um invite you to ask your
questions are you okay with that when
it's done I believe you're going to
leave thank you so um if I could then
please invite Willow Hawker Joy howth
Melody King and Daniel is it n NOS
NOS anybody I ever
mentioned what's your
name I can't hear from here sorry Toby
Brown Toby Brown thank you so if I could
invite you to what we're going to going
to do before you start this table will
come down off the stage and we're going
to go over to the side so that we can
watch your presentation is it okay thank
you
hi am Joy haor the chairman of the
council good evening I'm Toby Brown I'm
Vice chairman of rochard Youth Council
good evening I'm Willow hooker the media
officer for vard youth
Council uh so we just wanted to start uh
this evening by discussing what we've
achieved in the last year just as a kind
of to set a context for what we're going
to talk to you about next uh so the
mental health campaign has been the main
focus of our last year's work uh the
mental health campaign was something
that we started before the pandemic it
was voted on by the Make Your Mark
survey where mental health was voted as
the most important thing that young
people in the district decided that they
cared about the most so we took that and
we decided to turn it into a project so
during the pandemic we had to pause this
um just because we weren't able to meet
and we weren't able to kind of get young
people involved however after the
pandemic it has been revived and we have
finally managed to get it
completed this project encompassed us
commissioning a company called evolve to
deliver mental health workshops in all
schools in the district and this was a
series of two workshops across two
separate days where a group of uh 10 or
so students from each year groups 7 to
12 were 7 to 13 were allowed to um join
in on a session where they were given
resources and lessons and workshops and
activities that they could do together
and with trained professionals to learn
about mental health problems about
spotting the signs and with our main
slogan being reduce the stigma of Mental
Health
issues so we have received initial
feedback from the first uh two or three
uh sessions that um occurred and the way
that evolve tracked it was with uh
indicators from 0 to 10 across a
different uh bunch of different
measurements before and after the
workshops and we are really happy to
kind of um show that every single
student improved in every single
category at every single session so far
um after the two workshops so it's
really positive that we've had a um a
really strong and tangible uh response
from the from the workshop uh to keep
this going and to make sure we don't
lose momentum we've asked each person
that completed the workshop to take
their knowledge to take the skills that
they've learn and to become a mental
health Ambassador for their school in
their year group and hand out resources
and provide extra knowledge of people
that didn't get to attend but would
still like to know and would still like
help from them uh we also want to keep
these ties uh connected with the people
that we've worked with throughout this
project so we have um we've designed a
workshop to bring the people that
participated if they would like to to uh
Fitz wi Mar Center where we meet for a
uh Meetup where we're going to serve
pizza and drinks but also board games
and uh to discuss to talk with the
people and discuss what they found
really helpful about the workshop what
they thought uh was missed out what they
thought our next project should be and
obviously if they wanted to join the
youth Council as we're always trying to
recruit um the next thing is we held our
AGM which will we happen every year in
November uh with this we had a reshuffle
of the roles um we have our new chairman
Joy uh I Ste down as Vice as chairman
into Vice chairman uh to focus on my a
levels and we also elected new roles for
new members that joined since last
November uh we also amended our poster
so we're trying to embrace technology a
bit more make it easier to access
information about the youth Council
we've added a QR code we've changed the
colors to make it more accessible for
people with visual difficulties and
we're really excited that we've got this
new poster and we're spreading it across
social media and putting up train
stations schools local libraries places
like that and then uh the final thing is
we designed a Q&A leaflet which was
aimed at Bridging the Gap between what
actually is a youth Council and what
people already understand about the main
counil Council so we wanted a way for us
to explain to young people that the
youth council is a way uh to kind of get
your voice out there to help change
things to actually act on the things
that you might feel and things they
might think and we think it's a really
interesting and useful resource that we
can now give out at community events
like the one that was held here uh
earlier this year or last year thank
you um so the events that we've
attended um we did the Mill Hall like
cost of living event in which we came
here and we feel that this helped with
our recruitment as we gave out flyers
both inside the event itself as well as
going outside the event at the time and
giving out more flyers in an attempt to
recruit more people as Toby said we
always looking to recruit people um we
just wanted to show that we are involved
in the community and we want to continue
to be
involved we the youth voice
Conference was held by the youth ethics
assembly and they talked
about
different uh like things that young
people face and how these are prevalent
and young people got the chance to speak
and it was about making sure that young
people's voices are
heard and then the ra Mount Centenary we
went um we met some of the members of
the council and it is one of the reasons
why we're here today which is why we
thought it was important to put on the
PowerPoint then our ongoing projects uh
continuous ongoing projects obviously
recruitment
as we always need new members as we
always want to have as much youth voice
as we can in in trying to recruit people
we've also been to King George's Park
most
recently and it has allowed us to talk
to the youth and find out what they want
as we're also waiting on the Make Your
Mark results so we can also help with
our next project based B off of what
that comes out of and then the currently
we are working on getting a youth center
in Ry I we think it's important for the
Youth to have somewhere safe that they
can go during
evenings as the night isn't exactly a
friendly place to
be as there's a lot of knife crime as
you may be aware and so in doing this
we've got almost all of it set up we
just need to talk to the head of fit
about when like what day and what time
we'd be able to host this to make sure
that everyone that we can hold it as
often as
possible in terms of future
ideas um we need to sustain the youth
center I have only been chairman for 3
months and we already nearly have this
project up and running as Willow said we
just need to talk to the Head Master
fits and then it will be ready to go and
Willow and I are going to
volunteer another future project is
going to be painting the Planters in
King George's Park since there's like
cylinders like cement cylinders that no
one really knows what they are and they
basically used as bins but we wanted to
plant some stuff in there and paint the
outside so that they they look a bit
nicer and brighten up the
place we also wanted to do a project
about Safety near schools just because I
think it's important for people to feel
safe near schools since there there's
not nearly enough crossings that are
safe or um like lollipop
people we also getting results for the
Make Your Mark
voting which is where the young people
vote on important issues that are going
to be discussed in youth Parliament and
we listen to those results as well so
the the projects in the future are going
to be led by that thank you for
[Applause]
listening any
questions right if I could just do if I
came if you know some we keep it in
order because otherwise you'll be
everything will be coming at you at once
so just a tip the thing is that what I'd
like to say first of all thank you very
much for that it was really informative
it proves to me that you've done an
awful lot and it shows that you're an
very important platform for this Council
to to to take into employment because
you you're that link for our younger
people so I'm totally impressed by what
you said I for one think you have a real
chance here and we've got a lot of good
members here obviously but now I'm going
to take you
further
can
good I don't have a question but I would
like to congratulate you all on the
Fantastic work that you've done across
the district so well done and thank you
thank
you c m
Prof thank you chairman um couple of
questions and couple of uh points um
first of all again well done we need
more young people joining the youth
Council to have a louder voice here in
Rochford
um I tried to have a little look when I
saw that you were coming on to um just
have a little bit of research um and our
officers and our Council can do more to
support you I had a look on the
website it was last updated on your work
in uh I think it was March
23 so that needs update meting so these
guys here can help you more um and also
you don't appear in our social media
feed on the rire district council
Facebook much so hopefully that could be
improved I have to say though I found
most of the information on your lead
member who just spoke councelor Mrs
gooding's page who's been sharing Lots
including your news article in the Echo
which I would urge anybody to read um so
that is just one one bit and my question
was how was it identified as ra for um a
youth club across the district um it was
identified because the outside is
intended to be a youth club it says it
on the outside of six y Mark six form
but no one knows what it's about really
and there's no events apart from our
meeting so we wanted to make it more out
there so that people actually use it as
as intended
purpose thank you
any other members C
[Music]
Mason thank you chairman and thank you
so much your whole team for coming and
speaking to us um you did it with really
really well very very clearly fantastic
support with with media as well um I was
very impressed with all that you've
achieved in such an amazingly short time
I've got an invitation for you
um the council is currently in course of
creating a new strategic plan the
Strategic plan will run from this year
2024 till the carbon neutral pit date of
2030 and to do so we need to engage with
all sorts of people organizations we
need to engage with stakeholders and I
couldn't think of a better stakeholder
than you guys
so the invitation is please will you
join us um when we get round to
Consulting with stakeholders will you
join us and help us create a new
strategy for our
district I would love to do that I'm
delighted thank
you thank
you councelor James
newort thank you chairman um yeah
congratulations um you all speak very
confident ly and in fact lot better than
myself but what I'd like to know and I'm
really interested in um your youth club
that you're going to set up or in the
process of setting up and how are you
and how is the youth Council funding
that and is there something any way in
which we can help with that thank
you I don't think it's funded very well
currently I mean it doesn't exist yet
but when it does it probably be funded
very well but we do have things already
there since like as I said it was
intended for that so there already is
like games and things that we can do and
we are currently redoing the room that
we do our meetings in already with the
um with the youth workers money so it
would be great to have your support but
yeah it would be great to have your
support councelor Mrs
Mason
thank you chairman I'm not going to
repeat what everyone said because I
think we have a wonderful cross party
agreement on this which is nice to see
but all I will say is that I wish I had
half the ability that you have
demonstrated all of you tonight I'm well
done and thank you thank okay councelor
Mr
[Music]
Shaw thank you chairman when you go out
I'd like to give you my card because I'm
an County counselor and I'm also active
travel for safe schools so if you give
me a ring we can have a meeting and
hopefully I can give you some
information who to contact so on your
way out thank you thank you councelor
Mrs
butcher thank you chairman and thank you
youth Council um just to put it in
perspective I'm a retired youth worker
and I've been involved with youth
councils for a long long time and many
of the me members have gone on to become
uh District counselors Parish counselors
and even MPS so I'm I'm sure that uh you
will all have that opportunity as well
in the future but I do have one question
have you got members of the youth
Council from the whole
District currently we do not have that
many members at all but most people
live most people don't live that far and
we're all quite close together but as
we're trying to recruit we're trying to
get people from more across Rochford yes
because it's Rochford District Council I
would like to see members from other
parts of the district absolutely come
come together as well thank
you can
stepto thank you chairman um great to
see you here this evening one of the
things that a previous youth Council
used to do was to come along and I'm
could use the word
interrogate the senior executive members
or senior councils I just wonder whether
it would be something you'd want to
consider to do uh to get a good idea of
how the council works and do you see
yourselves becoming counselors in the
years to
come thank you for the recruiting
program well I think that's enough I
think these young people have done an
extremely good job I'm really impressed
a little bit of business plan there and
they've shown real abilities so I think
it's good for the future um I'd like to
thank you for coming you're free to
leave now if you so wish and so you get
we'll carry on with our business thank
you very much thank
[Applause]
you
thank you members uh we can get back to
that was very interesting but we'll get
back to item six now then on the agenda
public questions there is one public
question received from Mr John pton Mr
John pton are you free to come and put
your
[Music]
question you want to address yourself no
okay uh this is to the leader of the
council it is understood that currently
there are commercial issues which
temporarily prohibit this Council from
releasing more information and an update
concerning the asset delivery program
however when these issues are resolved
will the leader agree that the council
will bring forward a formal public
inquiry into the asset delivery program
so that lessons can be learned
documented reviewed publicly and all
information be brought to the attention
of the tax payer in a timely and
transparent
manner joh
motion thank you
chairman just like to thank Mr Peyton
for his question which I'll now
answer whilst the council is not able to
hold a public inquiry like the
government the council utilizes its
overview and scrutiny Committee in
reviewing Council decisions and this
committee has reviewed previous
documents and decision making and made
relevant recommendations on the
ADP the council has undertaken external
Independent Health Check reviews of the
asset delivery program health check
reviews are an essential element of
strong governance where the process
provides an independent assessment of
the health of a project ahead of key
decisions on the 11th of October
20122 the executive was presented with a
health check review by local
Partnerships on the ADP local
Partnerships is owned by hm Treasury and
the local government Association and
offers professional independent support
to public bodies in the review of
strategic projects
the overview and scrutiny committee
considered the health check review of
the asset delivery program at its
meeting on the 4th of October
222 this health check review is
published in the public
domain furthermore the council
previously commissioned a health check
review of the ADP by local Partnerships
in February
2019 a of drafting of the final business
case once the council is able to do so
it will release the elements of
information it is legally able to do in
order to demonstrate the council's
decision making regarding the
ADP at that point the council can
consider with the chair of the overview
and scrutiny committee whether a further
review is required on the ADP by the
overview and scrutiny committee thank
thank you
chairman thank you councelor Mason We
Now go to item eight questions on
notice sorry I've jumped
[Music]
[Applause]
over petitions yes are there any
petitions there are
none
item
[Music]
eight members questions on notice
okay
[Applause]
cible got two stuck together here we
go
right okay right there are three member
questions on notice question one
councelor Ian Ward I'm going invite you
to put your question on no
please thank you chairman um this is to
the executive lead member for strategic
planning until the change in political
Administration last May conservatives
had a very clear and wellp publicized
policy and declared in the annual
monitoring report its preference to
build on Brownfield sites before
developing Greenbelt
Land can the lead member for strategic
planning please tell us what the current
administration's position
is thank you thank you C Jim
grips thank you chair thank you
Ian
in response to the question about where
we
stand this new administration supports
the optimization of Brownfield
opportunities in accordance with the
mppf
criteria in our very first planning
policy meeting in July 23 we
demonstrated our support in supporting
the reworking and update of the
Brownfield register and then went on to
introduce the interactive location map
of the Brownfield sites both available
on the council
website we believe the register has been
given an appropriate level of attention
so far and we are committed to revisit
the register again during
2024 I would close by highlighting the
context of the
register the 33 potential sites could
generate Circa 15% of the new local plan
homes Target a very welcome
contribution we support the use of
Brownfield thank you okay so w do you
want to make a supplementary question
yes thank you very much indeed chairman
um it's just uh with reference to the
planning policy committee on the 17th of
October
2023 um I moved a motion which was
seconded by Council Foster that the
council should comply with the mppf
statement that planning policies and
decisions should promote the effective
use of land making as much use as
possible of previous developed or
Brownfield land and I do not understand
actually the voting because on that
particular day uh members voting in
favor of the motion were myself
councelor Foster and councelor stepto
were in favor but both yourself counc
Crips Council Hoy uh a deputy leader and
Council newo a deputy leader actually
voted against the mppf and uh you know
I'm very pleased that you've actually
come back and said that you do agree
with it but I was quite surprised in
what happened in that meeting thank you
and why can Crips do you wish to reply
you don't have
to yes it's very easily expl
um I don't think we need a sound bite uh
to demonstrate our commitment I think
the cross party planning policy
committee has worked together closely
and well and we'll be doing so again on
Friday when we've got yet another
Workshop to tackle some of the other
issues
and there is no doubt that we are I'll
make it quite clear there is no doubt
that we support
Brownfield which has to meet the
criteria of the
mppf rules and that's a given thank you
thank you we'll now go on to question
two I invite councelor e Gadson to read
out your
question uh my question is to the
executive lead member for the Strategic
planning at the 14th of December's four
council meeting I proposed a motion on
notice relating to Gypsy and traveler
pitches this was attend intended to
address a real and current problem
designed to protect the green belt band
B green belt from inappropriate
applications the response from the
administration was an amendment which
referred it to the planning policy
committee the chairman of planning
policy committed to providing short-term
Solutions though would not commit to a
time scale my question to lead member
for strategic planning therefore is why
did the Gypsy and traveler issue not
even get onto the agenda for the
planning policy committee meeting held
on the 16th of January thank you CC
Crips thank you chair thank you
Council
[Music]
the simple answer is that
uh very strange circumstances occurred
coincident with the Christmas area and
I'll Endeavor to explain to you why it
didn't come to the
committee the January planning policy
agenda was driven by the pre- Christmas
delivery of two large officer
reports from both Dan Goodman and Phil
dra and the objective was to get them
written by those authors before they
left the
council Dan Goodman left the day after
the full Council you're referring to the
field drain a few days later in the
remaining week before the seasonal
break their Replacements were due to
start in January after the
break because of that it was obvious to
me that research and a meaningful report
on the longstanding g&t issue could not
be delivered before the meeting
deadline and the meeting deadline for
the Christmas break was very harsh so
that Corporate Services could get them
out on time in the new
year however with the help of Officer
dun we met with the incoming new
director of place and the new corporate
manager of development and
enforcement and brief them in detail on
this
subject the groundwork work is now
underway and I intend to brief the
planning policy members this coming
Friday during our next Workshop
session so in a nutshell we couldn't
tackle that because we
were absent in terms of numbers in the
planning department to deal with it and
as you said in your
Preamble I made a point of not
committing to a time
scale thank you
C do you wish to come back with another
question
yeah is the lead member for strategic
planning aware that enforcement notice
for tendin Avenue ra Gypsy and traveler
site was
overturned by the appeal on appeal
granted by the planning inspector does
he not agree that urgent action is
required to adopt unauthorized sites to
avoid more speculative purchase of green
belt land and further applications being
granted on on existing Gypsy and
traveler sites that have already been
refused by this Council I would also
like to know when will this report be
issued to us members that you mentioned
at the last
meeting chairman this is not a
supplementary question and it does not
relate to the original
question thank you Cas I did allow it to
run because I I was waiting for it to
blend in with what was being said
earlier but clearly it doesn't so I
don't see that as a supplementary so I
shall admit that unless C Crips wants to
answer it I'll give him that privilege
if he doesn't he doesn't no thank you
chair thank you we now move on then
unless you have that other supplementary
you
haven't no okay so we move on I question
three will have to be passed on because
quite simply U councilor FD who had the
question is not available so we'll just
move that question on CC
B um just just to check we thought it
was the understanding was that the
chairman would read the the question on
the members behalf as has happened
previously at an executive meeting um if
that's not the case fine but that's what
Daniel was expecting I've not been
approached by that un as I've not been
approached an officer I'm not aware of
it so that that was the understanding
we'll carry it through C the
motion I would welcome the question to
be put by you because I believe it will
assist the residents and members of the
council to understand U the position um
of the administration in relation to the
issues raised and if I we don't get the
opportunity it'll be left and I don't
want that to happen okay I do not have
the do we have a copy of the
question question in the P thank
you okay if you're all if that's so all
right with the leader then and you wish
me to read that I will read that on
behalf of councelor FD
to the leader Financial appraisal for
Rochford District council's 20130 Net
Zero carbon Target report page 74
paragraph 23 States the initial survey
of Freight House identified that
significant investment in building
fabric measures such as insulation of
solid walls and windows upgrades made
the cost prohibited this appears to
suggest that with no budget provision in
20242 the house will be muff bored and
left to Rob furthermore the intention is
to sell off and vacate the council
premises in South Streets Rochford with
the current administration's declared
intent to reopen the Civics weite in Ry
reopen Castle Hall in Ry maintain the
mill halling ra despite no clear plan to
run the cost effectively can the leader
please outline his
vision his vision St it Council mate
I just turn out there's nothing on
there oh this is okay one
line say that the Regeneration of
councel assets will be there in the east
of will be there in the east of the
district i. specifically in Rochford
town okay that's the question Council
Mason
thanks thank you chairman for admitting
the the question and reading it um I'd
just like for the record to thank
councilor FD for his
question the council's intention is to
always work with key stakeholders to
help shape the future of our places and
the development of Rochford is something
that can only be done with the
community The Joint Administration has
listened and at the executive committee
on the 8th of February the following was
added to the budget which will be
considered a full Council
next week on the 20th of February
£25,000 per year marked to enable the
consultation an engagement to take place
with our residents businesses and key
stakeholders in respect of the
Regeneration opportunities in Rochford
taking into account all couns loed
assets such as South Street and Freight
House just for clarity I expect that the
council will have completed its research
on a range of options for both the
future of the South Street premises and
The Freight House soon after the
beginning of the next Municipal year
there will then be a period of public
engagement and consultation on the
options which will then be reviewed by
appropriate specialist Consultants
before the council is presented with
final options ahead of any decisions
being
taken this way the council will create
the shared Vision working
collaboratively with its residents and
Key State stakeholders I think this is
what councilor FD was seeking from his
question thank you thank
you right so now we move on to item
nine which is one item the business from
the last council meeting uh in the hands
of notice a motion proposed by councelor
Roger
[Music]
conable thank you Mr chairman uh the
motion is that Rochford District Council
will hold all committee meetings of
either full Council or the executive
during the evening to ensure that
maximum inclusivity for both counselors
and members of the
public councelor D Dan Bon thank you I
would like to second second that motion
and reserve the right to speak later in
the evening thank you m we have this
this notes a motion is there any members
would raise any questions regarding this
motion counc nle
thank you chairman um I won't be
supporting this motion chairman um
there's provision for this in the
Constitution and I know there is in the
uh proposed Constitution tonight um this
would this could impede the council
needing to carry out urgent business and
that that meeting though all meetings
may need to take place in the day so I
won't support this motion thank thank
you no proposition okay so then we we oh
counc Belton I'm happy to come back now
if members have finished speaking um I I
hear what council Newport has said but
urgent meetings need to be met uh
attended by members and often members of
the public and many of us are not
available at short notice during the day
because many of us have jobs and we know
that recruiting members to this Council
can be challenging and we need to make
it accessible to as many people as
possible given that the two meeting that
have taken place in the day recently one
of them was very short lasted 10 or 11
minutes I wasn't able to attend the
other had to be abandoned after even
less minutes if people have taken annual
leave to come away from work or whatever
their obligations are to attend those
meetings people with children it
affected School runs I think it's really
dis disadvantageous to have meetings
during the day and whilst I respect
Council nul's opinion about urgent
meetings being needed they can be done
in the evening or earlier in the evening
as we have seen with um chief officer
appointment meetings so I don't agree
with what he's saying I don't think it
would impede this Council and I think
evening meetings are more accessible to
the majority thank you thank you
councelor
Hoy thank you chairman um without
repeating anything I completely agree
with councilor Mr newort I would point
out that previously under the previous
administration
every licensing committee was held
during the day and I heard no complaints
from the um current opposition on that
when they were in administration I I
would not be supporting the motion thank
you thank you well I I think we've heard
yes
cancel yeah Mr chairman I understand
that licensing is always held during the
day for that very purpose and I expected
that not to be included within that
motion because licensing is always held
during the day so if you want to put an
amendment to it that apart from
licensing I would be happy to propose
that amendment to
it well there been sorry need to just
check the counil bu Amendment counc
would you accept that amendment I would
accept that Amendment because licensing
needs to be during the day because we're
inviting Professionals in as part of
their working day often so makes perfect
sense happy to support that Amendment
okay so do we need a second for that no
that's fine the proposer and the second
both agree with that amend so what is
the amendment now then
so admitting it would say accept for
accept accept for licensing committee
okay right members I think CC M
nle hey chairman I'm just speaking to
the amendment um chairman today I've
returned from a meeting at Essex County
Council sat in a room with 75 other
County councilors or 74 um none of them
seem to have a problem with attending
the meeting in the day in fact councelor
Shaw and councelor stepto was there as
well I didn't hear any grumbles from
them about the
timings
and most of I think all of the meetings
I go to are at County all so I don't
really see this being an issue as I said
previously I won't be supporting this
motion Council
won thank you chairman uh look I think
to start making comparisons between
councils all this Council does this and
that Council does that we're talking
about Rochford District Council here and
what we're talking about inclusivity
there are business reasons and practical
reasons as to why the licensing
committee is held during the day no
one's got any issues with that but this
is about making our meetings inclusive
and available uh for all members when
people take on a particular function uh
with respect County councilors certainly
in Essex realize that the meetings are
during the day that is part of the
commitment and equally when members take
on the role uh and are elected to take
on the role as members in rord District
Council the expectation is that the
meetings will be in the evening so it is
nothing more than inclusivity thank you
Mr chairman okay Mrs
Mason thank you um
Mr chairman
sorry you forgot who you were I can't do
that can I I'll May one of those moments
don't worry I shall join you willingly
um I'm a little bit I'd like some
clarity I know licensing and appeals
have been held traditionally in the
daytime and I must admit personally this
calls me and some of my members an issue
my understanding was that was a choice
but that licensing hearings and appeal
hearings had to be in the daytime but
not necessarily the committee meetings
so I would just like to if my
understanding is
correct um then I don't see the need for
the amendment but it's entirely up to
the proposer and second it so so could
someone give me some clarity on that
please can I ask em if you could just
clarify it
pleas thank you chairman good evening
members yes that's absolutely right um
licensing appeals hearings are held in
the daytime because they require the
person applying for the license to
appear and often their legal
professionals or other
Representatives um Licensing and
Regulatory committee deals with
licensing policy so that could very well
be held in the evening because that
tends to be just members and officers
thank you chair CC Mrs Milton um I would
just like to thank Mrs Mason for make
councelor Mrs Mason for making that um
Clarity I was certainly referring to the
appeals and the hearings that happen
during the day which are often difficult
to find cover for and we all have to
have substitutes further explo showing
the fact that daytime meetings can be a
challenge so I would be happy to revert
back to the original motion if Council
or conable is in agreement because
actually it's covered um in the
wording Mr chairman I'm happy for that
Amendment it was my confusion between
hearings and committee meetings thank
you okay
counc M
motion uh thank you Mr chairman may i'
now speak to the substantive motion
which I think we back to rather than the
amendment and I must admit I have always
found the um
licensing meetings in the afternoon's
difficult and I think that detracts from
people
attending I would support this motion I
do believe the evening meetings which is
our custom and practice and it has been
as long as I've been on the council with
the exception of Licensing unfortunately
um which is a good dozen years has and
before that I believe has always been
7:30 in the evening bearing in mind that
we are a commuter area and the reason
for the 7:30 start and I I know we don't
want to be that prescriptive but the
reason for the 7:30 start is that
residents and members that work in the
city can reasonably attend an evening
meeting without too much disruption to
their daytime so I will be supporting
the motion thank you back to the
original motion AR we counc H you wish
to
speak I find it quite sad that members
of this Council are so oldfashioned and
out of dat that they don't understand
flexible working they don't understand
shift work they don't understand night
work in other words I don't understand
that people do not work 9 till 5
nowadays
many people may do it doesn't mean
everyone does and I think by restricting
meetings just to the evening with no
other option restricts this council's
ability to recruit counselors and
restricts this council's ability to do
proper work I will not be voting for the
motion thank you members I think we've
had the fors and against and we're back
to the original motion so I intend to
take a vote on that motion and so if we
just read that motion again that
Rochford District Council will hold all
committee meetings on either for of
either for Council or executive during
the evening to ensure that maximum
incity of both counselors and members of
the public all those in
favor who's
can thank you members those against
[Music]
thank you no and any abstentions
members
to oh sorry I'm just going to because I
chair members
the that is carried there 18 for 16
against and three abstentions so that is
carried motion thank
you we now move on to item
10 to note the minutes of the executive
committee meetings held between the
period of 27th of November to the 23rd
November 2023 to the 16th of J January
as listed uh are are all those minutes
noted
members thank
you item 11 item 11 to consider any
reports from the executive and committee
to C committees to counselors 111 report
of the planning policy committee local
development scheme and cancer
crits
so I'll do it again he wasn't
listening so we're looking at item 111
report planning policy committee local
development scheme 2024 26 Council Crips
I believe you're the to introduce this
report chairman unfortunately councilor
CPS can't hear you so could you speak up
please you can't hear me oh
sorry oh you haven't got I understand
okay right ccor Crips the the the next
question is 11 111 is the report of the
planning policy committee local
development scheme 20 2024 to 2026 I
understand you're producing that report
correct yes would you do so
please
oops this went through the planning
policy committee on the 16th of January
it's quite a large document um it's also
something mandatory that we have to
produce I'm quite happy to put this
forward now uh the committee were happy
with it and I trust the council will be
happy with it thank you thank you do we
have a proposal for this do we have a
proposal for this uh
report yeah iOS sorry proposed by
councelor cryson do we have a second
second all of
you councelor Mason John Mason okay
thank you are there any questions on
this
can thank you chairman I would like to
actually um make a statement with regard
to this report if I may um I believe
officers are factually wrong in implying
that the deadline for the plan making
under the current system is likely to be
extended Michael go has explicitly
stated that 30th of June 2025 is the cut
off date authorities that authorities
that do not meet the submission deadline
for old style plans will need to prepare
plans under the new system this would
result in a significant amount of
abortive work and wasted time and
financial resource the timetable set out
in the proposed LDS 2024
2026 does not propose submission for
examination until quarter 3
2025 which would clearly missed the
deadline set out by the Secretary of
State it would be critical for Rochford
to meet the 30th of June 2025 deadline
to avoid having to start again from
scratch and in accordance with a new
plan making process the final details of
which are not yet known but it's been
suggested in consultation material
that plan making will follow a 30mon
program it should be further
acknowledged that it will be a local
election in Rochford May
2024 there will likely be a general
election this year too during any
election campaign there are pre-election
periods of heightened sensitivity where
there are purther restrictions on what
can be done particularly in relation to
the development of policy or new cons
ations on this basis we can expect two
periods amounting to Circa 3 months in
total over the course of 2024 where the
potential to progress the local plan
will be styed this adds a further
challenge to meeting the June 2025
deadline however we do consider this to
be achievable with focused effort and
intention the legislation provides that
the council must undertake both a
regulation 18 and regulation 19
consultation under reg 18 part one the
special options document was subject to
consultation in
2021 reg 18 part two now requires the
preferred options document for public
consultation under regulation 89 the
local planning Authority must before
submitting a local plan to the Secretary
of State make a copy of the proposed
submission documents available and an
opportunity for representations to be
made all of which need factoring in our
recommendation is that there is a
feasible option available to Rochford to
submit a local plan in advance of the
30th of June 2025 deadline the council
would need to revisit the overall
program and expedite the preferred
options to June and July 2024 with an
immediate view to undertaking
consultation on the preferred options
document immediately following the local
election in May 2024 before the summer
recess this will require concerted
effort to progress the evidence-base and
the draft local plan with immediate
effect to be able to achieve this
following this the regulation 19
consultation would need to follow and in
early 2025 to Avail a window of
opportunity prior to the June 20125
deadline if the preferred options public
consultation does not take place in the
summer of 2024 there is still an Avenue
available to skip this stage and
progress directly to regulation 19
pre-submission public consultation in
quarter 1 2025
if the council one more minute thank you
if the council elect to proceed in line
with the LDS 2024
2026 as presented to in the four Council
committee papers it is highly likely
that Rochford will be required to go
back to square one and commence the plan
making process under the emerging new
system this would mean that there would
not be a new local plan to guide growth
and development until
2028 thereby leaving this Council open
to unknown changes and difficult to
defend speculative planning applications
and I would like to hand this over to
whoever's doing the committee minutes to
present this plus the plan that I have
on the back I'd like to hand this over
to uh Jonathan quter sitting here and
then he can take that plan thank you
very much chairman you're one second
over
thank you for that is there any other
comments councilor M
Shaw um regarding the Strategic
transport assessment has been done by
independent um
Consultants what I'd like to know and
the question is has any of these data
been given to ess6 County Council and I
made investigations yesterday and today
and I can actually say it
hasn't so when the um consultation does
go to eics how long will it take to come
through and how much would it cost has
the count RDC actually costed this out
or ask the ess6 County Council how much
this will cost thank you very much than
you counc Crips do you have a reply for
that
question thank you chair I i' have to
defer to the professional officer for a
response on that
okay thank you chair um yeah so in terms
of the transport assessment that work
has obviously been done in conjunction
with ESS County Council so they are
working with our Consultants to prepare
that work already um so they they're but
currently in the stage of looking
through the the framework of that that
works so in terms of the the way that's
modeled um and that will um effectively
be then you B for in terms of them
accepting whether that's the the
appropriate basis to assess uh the
impacts on the transport net n work so
it's an ongoing process it's not going
to be a case it's finished it's going to
be ongoing up until the point of
submission and through the examination
process that's that's the same for a lot
of local plans um so I think it is clear
to say that that's obviously been costed
from the case of Rocher Council the
money that we're paying towards the
consultants and obviously part of their
work they have to work with the County
council's Highway Authority um so that
is in
hand
shaw that didn't actually answer my
question I actually asked have they got
the costings and I was I am part of es
highways I'm Deputy C member and I've
actually asked the officers who would be
dealing with this nobody knows about
this so that's what I'm saying I've had
a report and we were at Council today
nobody had any idea of this so I want to
know my question was how long um How
much would it take how much is it going
to be which you obviously couldn't
answer and I would prefer to be truthful
that you actually don't know the answer
and if you could come back privately to
me tell me which officers you are
dealing with because my officers don't
know anything about it thank you very
much thank you thank you right can
Steptoe you wanted to did you want to
reply to that Mr
quill thank you chair um yes so so the
officers that we're working with Mark
Robinson who's the strategic planning um
transport officer uh there's also um the
the colleagues in Jacobs I think OB
they've appointed to assist with that
work um so I'm yeah I'm not entirely
sure exactly what the the question was
in regards to the costings is that in
relation to the actual work itself what
do you mean in terms of the the eventual
mitigation measures for example because
obviously that work is still
ongoing stand up how much RDC are paying
out for the how much is RDC paying on
this please I can provide rather than
trying to provide an answer top my head
I to announce that in writing so thank
you very much thank you C step
[Music]
to thank you chairman uh picking up on
the uh uh the plan the Strategic plan I
have a great concern in fully supporting
this uh these recommendations at this
stage because without having sight of
the plan and understanding
it that it will have such a large role
in determining where housing needs to be
I can't support it at this stage it we
need to fully understand what that
strategic plan is as far as transport
and infrastructure is concerned
particularly on our neighbors because
they will have a big effect on us
particularly south end so I'm finding it
very difficult at this stage to
fully support this particular
recommendations thank you okay so Mrs
mcf thank you
chairman um I would like to refer to 3.7
on page
11.1.2 around the evidencebased um
members here will probably remember that
back on the 31st of October I asked
Council grips around flood zone
areas um it is at
1.24 in that recording of that meeting I
say in the recording of the meeting
because it wasn't actually included in
the minutes but it is there in the
recorded word um I asked that within the
criteria not only flood zones two and
three but also including one would would
be part of the sifting process but that
also the climate change bearing in mind
that we've announced a climate emergency
here at Rocher District Council would
also be taken into account because flood
zones one and two in the future will
become flood zones three there's no
argument at that meeting councelor Crips
confirmed they would so I just want to
reiterate is that still the case 3.7 in
that sifting process that they will be
taken into account and with climate
change thank you CC Crips can you answer
question thank you chair yes I can
confirm that during the early stages of
considering districts and likely uh
settlements we did
a slimming down exercise and some
criteria of what we would and what we
wouldn't uh use in selecting
places as far as the flooding was
concerned we said we would obviate the
phase the the category
three avoid the category two but
category one would would
remain I will come back because I think
perhaps councilor Crips might need to
listen to that recording from the
31st October because that wasn't it was
also to include flood zone one and take
it into account alongside climate change
um and 3.7 on page
11.1.2 does say in the last sentence
that the LDS is kept under review so it
can't be already part of a sifting
process because it's an ongoing process
I think that Council Crips will agree
with
that thank you chairman thank P
sorry councelor Crips um in the document
on uh 3.7 the last statement uh sorry
sentence says that is important
therefore that the LDS is kept under
review so I am presuming that means that
it's an ongoing review of the local
development
plan correct great so therefore no
sifting has already taken place of flood
zone one because it's an ongo
process okay okay I'll take your point
thank you right we're now going on to
Kon
wton thank you chairman look I have
absolutely no doubt that councelor Crips
is proposing this report with the best
of intentions but what concerns me is
the fact that councelor ward has raised
a number of issues really about process
and timing so I'm totally confused as to
which one is right or which one is wrong
so I don't think we can possibly accept
the reports and all of think we can do
is to seek some clarification um and
it's probably a deferral um until
members are properly informed as to the
process the timings uh and as I say not
bringing into question anything that
councilor crys has said but I don't
think this is something that could be
resolved tonight but in the absence of a
deferral I certainly can't support it
with so much doubt thank you Mr chairman
are you proposing a deferral then on
this case yes chairman that seems to be
very sensible I'll oos to
Def do you have a
second I'll second it can
M well members before we go any further
then we have a notice of deferral so we
can look further into this so um I'd
like to take a a vote now on whether to
support this suggested Amendment
councelor
Mason chairman would you agree that we
can speak to the deferment before taking
a
vote
sorry okay I'm informed that procedures
and deferments are voted on without
debate so we'll have to follow procedure
so no in answer to that I'm being
advised by my officer so we're going to
take a vote then so we're looking at a
deferment of a proposal that we defer
this agend this item while we can take
further you know further sort of
Investigation into
yes
sir
yeah thank you chairman just before we
go to defer I think the question from
councilor Ward was asked but I don't
think there's a chance for an officer to
respond so it might be just worth
Council um um Jonathan crter responding
first before you think about the
deferral because he might be to provide
some more information ahead of that
because one of the points Council Bo
made about the urgency of this so Defan
does go against that so if there is a
response that Jonathan cour can respond
before you think about the for it might
be worth hearing that well I'm all for
it if the members are happy so Mr
courton thank you chair can I just ask
you be a bit louder please I was
struggling with your last yeah apologies
no worries I can speak up um yes so
thank you Council Ward for the for the
notes and obviously presenting that and
yes you're correct obviously in terms of
your assessment of the situation as it
stands currently obviously the
government is proposing that by the 30th
of June next year and that would be the
deadline to be able to submit a plan
under the current the current system um
so yeah I do appreciate that what's set
out within the um development scheme
under this item uh which shows obviously
that the obviously that is a target date
I would suggest obviously we are we are
making sure we do this as quickly as we
can but we also have to be mindful of
those potential changes that could come
into play uh I believe that um Michael
go has announced that they would be
expected in the Autumn obviously in the
broadest sense this year that those
would be more formalized um so obviously
we've got the headlines for them at the
moment in terms of what the expect
ations are in terms of those Gateway
assessments where we have three stages
to Preparing that that plan um but that
obviously the more detail and the the
Practical elements of what will be in
the practice guidance nationally uh
won't be known until later this year um
but in terms of that development scheme
clearly the intention of that document
is to provide an upto-date view on where
we expect things to go and now clearly
we have to obviously constantly pivot
and change where there may well be those
other factors that could influence what
we need to do um this is not an uncommon
issue this is often the case of
preparing plans for you know for many
many years uh that we need to make sure
that we're reflecting what is the the
requirements in front of us clearly what
we don't want to be in a position of is
actually submitting a plan that is
knowingly unsound clearly it needs to be
a plan that we can as a council adopt
and it's you know legally possible to do
so um so really what I would suggest is
it's a case that with that development
scheme that um we are you obviously
keenly aware of that that deadline and
Our intention as it stands is to meet
that deadline um and certainly I suppose
it could well be a case if that was the
the main point of contention around
being quarter three that could be
changed to Quarter Two um so that could
show that could be um obviously that's
our intention that is the intention to
submit by that that 30th of June
deadline now clearly as as as we just
alluded to earlier this document has to
be kept live and up to datee and that is
a requirement to keep this timetable um
under review and changed as as
accordingly if we need to in future um
as of today you know that's our
intention is to make sure we can get a
plan submitted by that deadline so that
that would be my view anyway in terms if
that was a useful
suggestion thank you the
voting counc won um in view of what's
been said do you want to continue or
withdraw this um motion thank you
chairman uh look
there is a danger that I tread into an
area I know absolutely nothing about in
terms of the technical aspects but I'm
just simply looking at it from a process
point of view and I think it has been
acknowledged by the officer that
actually um this report is lacking in
terms of
definitive uh deadlines um because
clearly central government is
influencing uh by putting a a block that
change so um I'm not comfortable on
supporting the report as it stands on
process uh not necessarily about the
content and I reiterate the fact that I
know that it's been brought here with
the best of intentions but I'm not
actually comfortable about voting on
something where there is uh any
confusion at all and I think Council a
ward has brought that confusion and
that's actually in part been agreed by
Jonathan quilter and I appreciate that
uh that point of view thank you chairman
thank
you we need to
V right then M we' got take about yes
it's
quick thank you just a point that my
understanding is the concern is over the
timeline very bre briefly and if and the
officers of obviously supported this
report if we defer it we're going to
extend the timeline so I think it's case
of shooting ourselves in the foot but
I'm not sure
um uh but that's my understanding of
what I've heard from the officer thank
you well in view it I think we said
enough I we could have to make our minds
out for ourselves and the thing is we
have a notice a motion to defer so I'm
going to take a vote so all those in
favor for a deferment of this particular
item please raise your
hands thank you those
against
yeah thank you any
abstentions thank
you you got because we got
close
yes well that it's been um defeated but
those for it were 12 against 21 and
abstentions four so that's we'll go back
to the original um proposition then if
we may that we're now looking at the the
proposition that the local plan
development scheme 24 24 to 26 as ATT ta
and opinion 6 B be adopted and published
on the council
website councelor
Foster uh thank you chairman um without
going too much over what's already been
said um it's disappointing the uh road
traffic assessment started in the 13th
of October and it still appears there's
no end date to it when we get a a viable
and complete report um secondly I
noticed that this is a big complex job I
accept it's very disappointing or
surprising to see the budget for the
strategic planning department uh
portfolio to be reduced from
56,000 to
316,000 in the fourth coming
year CC Mrs
bin thank you um I'm I'm certainly no
expert on planning policy and I respect
the work that's been done by all the
members of that committee and the report
itself the my concern
is twofold we've been talking about a
deadline of June 2025 for quite some
time that is still publicly the deadline
that's being pushed by government
locally that is what our residents
expect and my concern is going back and
Now setting a deadline one year on is
unfair on our residents we have a large
number of groups right across the
district that are concerned about future
development if we miss this deadline of
2025 we are potentially at risk R of
unscrupulous developers coming in and
building whatever they want wherever
they want and that has always been a
huge concern of this Council and why de
the deadline has been so important to
meet so and it was a difficult one
because I didn't want to defer the item
because we don't want to delay it
anymore but I don't want to support a
report where I don't agree with the
timelines and I think we're putting this
entire District at risk of unscrupulous
developers so I can't support the Po in
its current state but because of the
timelines that have been stated within
it and certainly listening to what
Jonathan quilter said it's supported in
to my Layman understanding it supported
what council Ward said in terms of that
deadline still being a real and live
date of June 2025 so I would like to I
would have wanted to have supported the
report but I can't purely on
timings there's a
motion thank you chairman I I'm in um
new ground here because it's not
something that I've come across before
which must be quite remarkable in the
amount of time that I've spent in this
chamber um we we have a recommendation
from a committee um we have found um
that since the committee made its
recommendation that um there is now
considerable doubt over the timeline
that was included can I ask and ask ask
through you chair to um Emily y um is
there any way that for Council can amend
this recommendation at this point and
therefore re reset the um appropriate
line or lines in the timeline to comply
with what Mr quilter has been advising
us thank you
chairman you give us a
second
thank you chairman um I believe you're
referring Council Mason to the table
that's on page
1114 of the report um yes is the short
answer you could propose an amendment to
the recommendation along the lines of
subject to altering that timeline and
then put in your change that you wish to
to uh make to the T would we have to put
the timeline in or can we leave that
open um the chairman just asked if uh
the timeline needs to be put in
alternatively you could uh make a
Amendment to the recommendation that
gives delegated authority to the officer
in consultation with the relevant lead
member to adjust the timetable as
necessary to uh respond to any changes
um made by the
government can
W thank you chairman um I did pass a
document over uh to to Jonathan on on
the back I have amended that timeline as
a suggestion uh I don't know if other
members could possibly see it um I've
only got the the two copies
basically
what would happen if we if you got that
timeline and we find that to be wrong I
mean we need
[Music]
to yeah sorry
conation chairman I what what I had in
mind was just a simple restatement of um
one two or three lines um rather than
going through a uh a long process of
receiving um a statement from another
member so I would be recommending that
um Mr quilter and councelor Crips could
make such a proposal and amend the
report
appropriately
what they do they retire and come up in
time or just leave it open so that they
can motion can
Ved okay yeah good
thank you chair I've had an opportunity
to look at the proposed timetable from
councilor Ward um and because there
isn't just one amendment to it I think
my advice to the council would be um
that it's not appropriate at this stage
to make amendments and adjustments to
the timetable without that having fully
been considered by the technical
officers um and on that basis uh my
recommendation to the council would be
if you wanted to amend the uh proposed
recommendation it would be to include a
delegation to officers and the relevant
lead member to make adjustments to the
timetable as is necessary thank you
chair Mrs
B thank thank you um completely
understand what um Emily Y is saying my
concern is that is completely open-ended
and actually could further they could
change it to be further back in terms of
later um so could the wording not be to
incorporate to to amend it as required
in line with current deadlines or words
to that effect because I think the the
big concern here is if we miss the
deadline we either start the process
again or developers come in and do what
they want to our district so I think
it's it's about the the deadline being
met as opposed to the specific details
being changed within that table that
that's as I see it and as I understand
it and that's my concern for
residents conation did you want to speak
he didn't no
unfortunately
right could we have a short so I can
consult I think it's a good idea yeah
it's been requested by the officer and
I'm in full agreement that we're going
to take a short recess that give you a
comfort stop while they can take proper
advice and and guide this Council
properly and so we'll have at least five
or 10 minutes so if you want to take a
break and it's now just before 9:00
okay
if you'd like to return to your chairs
thank
you
members it's come we're now we're now
convening this meeting the time now is
9:15 and I want you to remember that
time because um a notice of importance
has come up we're going to just finish
with this item um and then I intend to
move uh before we go any further bring
items 14 and 15 forward because of the
importance of that tonight we must get
that done and I'm looking at the time
which then brings me on to reading you
an extension of meeting because I don't
think we're going to have enough time so
I'm going to read you this this is to be
read out when the meeting has lasted two
hours which it has obious will be
members the meeting is now lasted
roughly two hours I'd like to move a
motion without notice according to the
council's policy role 14 n to extend the
meeting beyond the two and a half hours
for as long as necessary in order to
complete the remaining business can I
have a
second coun Mrs Mason okay right can
those we need to extend so can we um
have a vote then to extend this meeting
before a normal threshold all those in
favor if we don't we won't f finish all
of our stuff tonight I'll tell you that
now so right all those in
favor thank you all those
against
where you go
15 I made it 14 one can you put your
hands up again
please okay thank you want make sure any
abstentions thank
you oh sorry you got it
there right the move to extend uh 14
against 16 and three abstentions that
means that we're not going to extend
before 10 o'clock and I will tell you
now we will by the looking at this we
ain't going to go to the end of this
agenda so I'm bringing 14 and 15 forward
as I said and we'll continue on until
we've reached our time stren thank
[Music]
you right we're just finishing off this
existing item so
okay you to canel the cits yeah have you
already okay cancel the cits are you in
possession of the new you I I believe
you wish to put another Mo an amended
motion thank you chair yes sorry I'd
like to prop propose propose a motion to
my original
motion and I
shall use this document which I should
called The Ward
memorandum
and we will change the date to match the
deadline on there Q2
2025 deadline on our own
document to match
that so that's the motion to change it
on our document to what this document
says Q2
2025 do we have a second to that
motion can Mr
Mason
right
canc could the luk just clarify which
line on the chart he's rering to because
it's not
[Music]
clear okay your cryp to oh you can't
hear okay do we yeah can yes please he's
not he's not he hearing again thank you
chair um I think I've got the nod from
councilor Crips to assist with this um
question so the line that's being
amended is the line in the table that
says submission to Secretary of State
for independent examination brackets
regulation 22 and that's being changed
to Q2 2025 currently it says Q3 thank
[Music]
you so okay so I wish to take a vote on
on that Amendment then so all those in
favor sorry you don't need to vote on
the amendment because the propos in SEC
oh so that's so that's go that's done
then okay thank you for that so we don't
need any vote so that's now Carri
forward thank you soor I'll give you
that back you thank you right so we're
now going to go to item now you're
voting on The substantive
motion right so we're going to take a
vote now on for the substantive motion
as amended right so all those in favor
sorry well that's made a
[Laughter]
[Music]
difference thank you all those
against any
extensions yeah
one thank
you members let carry 35 for no none
against one Extinction thank you so we
can move on we as I said because of
sorry if I may this is just a a quick
statement um councilor Mr newort has
asked me to say to you that he's had to
leave the meeting unfortunately due to
unforeseen circumstances thank you very
much we'll minute that thank you very
much so right now going to go on there
which we'll have to sort the BW but
we'll have to go on there to item 14 um
really because of the importance in the
time scan
so it agenda item 14 local council tax
support scheme 224 to two
2025 and the dis discretionary reduction
in council tax liability policy
20242 um Council H you wish to introduce
this thank you chairman apologize I'll
be using my phone because my laptop has
run out of charge and I can't don't see
we provided with plugs um agenda item 14
is the local T council tax support
scheme
20242 and the discretion reduction in
council tax liability policy
20242 I'm quite pleased to be able to
present this report because this is one
for many years I requested an amendment
on which was finally conceded by
councelor Simon Smith when he was here
um anyway this report seeks approval for
the council's local council tax support
scheme there are no proposals to alter
the scheme for
20242 the report also seeks approval to
continue the interim arrangements to
compensate those residents that lost out
as a result of changes to the scheme in
2022 the cost to the Council of doing
this in
20242 is £12,000 and it has been
anticipated in the budget for next year
I move the two recommendations and
apologies I've got to go to a different
screen which won't take me too
long find
it there lost um
the recommendations are recommendation
one the lcts scheme be confirmed from
1st of April 2024 recommendation 2 R2
the discretion reduction in council tax
liability policiy is continued from 1st
of April 2024 thank you chairman
yes Mrs
mcferson thank you so are there any
questions before we go any
further no then members we have a
proposition I'd like to take them on
block to the two at the same time if the
members are happy with this thank you so
the both schemes in you've heard them
I'll read them again anyway the lcts
scheme being confirmed from April 1st
2024 and secondly the discretionary
reduction of council tax liability Poli
policy is continued from April 1st
2024 now we're Tak it together all those
in
favor thank you any
against any
extensions well it's actually unanimous
so that that that carried thank you
members we now go on to item 15 review
of the polling districts and polling
places and I understand this will be in
the hands of our officer Emily
Yu thank you chairman I'm happy to
present this report on behalf of the
joint acting director for people and
governance and the Electoral services
manager the council is required to
designate polling districts and polling
places for the purposes of Elections the
returning officer then locates the
polling station within that polling
place there is a requirement to keep
these Arrangements under review and this
report sets out the results of that
review as you can see the outcome of the
review is very straightforward only one
change is recommended which is that the
polling place for the polling District
ja in hullbridge Ward be moved from St
Thomas of Canterbury Church to
hallbridge Community Center all other
polling places remain the same chairman
please could I ask for a proposer and
seconder and I'm happy to answer any
questions on the report thank you propos
caner I can't see I'd like to uh propose
that recommendation chair thank you and
a second councelor Mrs Mason thank you
are there any questions or can Mr
stepton thank chairman um it may be
something I can take offline uh with the
officer but I have a particular concern
where pubs are involved uh particularly
the one in my ward the amberin where it
is not a separate room within the bar
area I have a bit of a concern about
people having access to that and it's
not that secure perhaps I can talk to
the officer after the meeting and we can
look at that and see how we can improve
that facility for people voting thank
you no else can M go thank you chair
just a quick one just to understand
really the one recommendation um it
seems because Ward members have made the
recommendation that that's the one
that's been favored which is absolutely
f w members know their area is there any
reason that Resident suggestions haven't
been taken forward were they considered
and just not deemed viable given the
very low response it was just to
understand the process really because it
doesn't really give an awful lot of
detail on that thank
you thank you chairman a public
consultation has been
undertaken um but not a kind of targeted
consultation um so there hasn't been any
other feedback received about the
arrangements for that polling District
other than the comments received from
the Ward members thank you okay Mr
ho yeah thank you chairman for allowing
me to speak on this this
is something that residents have not
complained about but not been happy with
since the original polling station near
near the river and by Paul's Lane was um
not Ava made not available and since
then they've been using a church which
is
a long way from the majority of those
voting it's on the very edge of the next
W if you like in hridge so we as W
councilors have taken soundings from
residents the residents are very happy
for it to move the to the community
center and the community center is now
very happy to accept to have the poing
station um and I'd like to thank um Joel
Sullivan and the um elections team and
also the community center for working
hard to get this done thank you thank
you can Mr w
thank you chairman I accept I probably
made this uh request more informally
than it should do because I can't point
to any email or or correspondence but I
have said in the past that due to the
closure of King Edmund's school um it
was necessary for temporary reasons to
relocate the um polling station that
used to be there to Halt Farm School
quite understand the reasons um but I'm
just very very conscious it is actually
a long way for people near King edman
School brace Lane to travel I had made
that point informally to a number of
officers accepting I hadn't done it
formally but I really would like even at
this stage for officers perhaps to take
that away and have a little look uh to
see whether they could reinstate
something a little bit nearer to the
brace lane side on roach North and Rural
thank you Mr
chairman well we've U we've got this
um proposition um oh sorry sorry counc
coun
Council thank you Mr chairman um I had
representation from some of my residents
in South fanbridge um I don't know if
you know that area but it's probably two
mile three mile Journey from the the uh
fanbridge settlement up to where they
have to vote um and there was something
on the consultation about that and I
don't know why that hasn't been
considered for a temporary polling
station for the people of fanbridge as
they seem to be get and largely
forgotten out there thank you thank
[Music]
you right well I intend there's no one
else no I I intend to take these on
block if people are happy there's two
items here are you happy that I take
this on block okay then then we'll put
this proposition then that the polling
place for polling District ja in
holbridge will be moved from St Thomas
of Canterbury Church Thor Avenue
holbridge to holbridge Community Center
Pauls Lane holbridge
and two no further recommendations and
suggest that existing polling places
remain the same all those in
favor thank you all right thank
you I keep forgetting me sorry about
that thank you members
against any any
abstentions well that's unanimous so
that that proposition has been carried
thank you we're now going to revert back
to where we was on the current business
of item 112 I think it
was
yeah
yeah here we are right report of the
over and scrutiny committee treasury
management quarter uh three review 23 to
24 uh counc mcferson thank you chair I
will keep this brief because all members
have the report this is the third
treasury management report for the
financial year provid an update of the
council's treasury management activity
from April 2023 to 31st December
2023 the report came to overview and
scrutiny committee on the 1st of
February and the committee noted the
report and agreed its contents to uh to
be referred to the council the main
highlight being the excess income
generated from the investment which has
enabled a budget ation Reserve I propose
that to the council that this report be
noted chairman thank you members that is
for noting are you all happy with that
thank you thank you very much uh 113
report of the climate emergency
committee sustainability progress report
councelor
Hoy thank you chairman again I'm working
for my phone so I apologies for that um
this is the
um sustainability progress report um I
won't repeat word for word what's here
it just says that it's
um is pointing out the there's five key
targets which the report says how we are
meeting those or unable to meet those
and it just is just propose that the
council resolves that the sustainability
progress report is noted if anyone has
any questions I'm happy to answer or
Marcus hton will answer thank you thank
you so um
are there any questions on on this
particular item no you got that well
Marcus you got away with it so we take
those reading we now go on to item 12
revised Council Constitution the problem
I have here is councilor um nle who has
left the building for various reasons
and he was going to introduce a
rle can I ask are you in a position to
put that report
please thank you chairman and members
I'll be very brief as um this has come
unexpectedly this evening however I have
supported the Constitution working group
throughout its work so have a full
understanding of the uh conversations
and deliberations uh the revised
constitution in front of you this
evening members is the result of a
cross-party politically representative
working group um it's been a very
thorough and comprehensive review of The
Constitution uh we've spent many hours
together pouring over the various
provisions
um and adjusting the Constitution to
obviously meet the change to the
committee style of governance but also
to take the opportunity to update the
Constitution make it more modern and
make it more
accessible um chair I've provided a
member briefing on the update to the
Constitution which I know many members
in this room have attended um but I'm
very happy to take any technical
questions and would seek a proposer and
a seconder for the recommendation thank
you Hoy thank you thank you em thank you
chairman um could the officer State
whether or not the motion passed earlier
tonight on holding all executive
meetings in the evening is contrary to
what's said in the Constitution if it is
will the fact that the constitution is
being passed after that motion mean that
the constitution would override that
motion thank
you thank you chair um in the revised
Constitution Within the council
procedure rules um there is a provision
that uh meetings of the council all
meetings whether they're the council or
committees uh will usually be held at
7:30 p.m. um so that doesn't conflict
with the the uh motion that was passed
earlier all that it means is that if any
meetings are convened outside of that
usual time slot they now need to be in
the
evening any other questions sorry
chairman I didn't hear the last few
words of
that sorry chair it's just that if any
meetings are convened outside of that
usual 7:30 p.m. time slot they would
need to be in the evening to comply with
the motion carried by the council
earlier
today sorry just for clarity then that
the Motions that will exist and will
override the
Constitution as we're voting on
now do you want me to respond yes please
thank you chairman for the opportunity
to respond um it doesn't neither
overrides the other they can coexist um
all that it means is if a meeting is
held outside of the provision of the
Constitution usually at 7:30 p.m it
would have to be in the evening rather
than any other time of the day so they
can coexist
together con
motion thank you chairman um through you
I'd like to just ask for a simple
clarification um the term meetings has
been used does that apply to working
groups and other less less formal than
committee
meetings you we're just looking
out chairman I'm just going to double
check the drafting of that
[Music]
provision
thank you chair for allowing me to just
double check that um the um revised
Council procedure rule five deals with
the time and place of
meetings um and it talks about the
calendar of meetings as uh agreed by the
council um and then it goes on to say
meetings will usually commence at 7:30
pm so it only refers to formal council
committee or subcommittee
meetings
Okay do we have a do we have a proposal
for this um council Mrs
moson uh thank you Mr chairman I am more
than happy to propose this uh report as
you know the
Constitution working group has worked
hard it's worked cross party it's worked
collaboratively it's worked
constructively and at all times the
members because it was cross party were
to go back to their groups to make sure
there was consensus going along so I'm
sure that I would like to propose that
this report is Mo is carried thank you
thank you do I have a
second coun Mr Mas
then members we have a proposition to
adopt uh as this proceeding sorry oh Cas
a step
down thank you chairman um I'd like to
propose
amendment a small Amendment um I do so
on behalf of council Lefty who was going
to be here sey and I was going to Second
his Amendment so I've now been in a
position to bring It
Forward I read I'll read what it
says the subcommittee dealing with
complaints about
counselors that at least one independent
person sit on the working party and Par
and a one Parish
counselor the Independent party to Pro
promote full
transparency
transparency as a committee just made up
of officers members and members of R RDC
may be accused of being
secretive and a parish
counselor to have an understanding of
Parish
issues I would suggest that perhaps the
parish counselor if this is agreed be
nominated by the rodford Hun Association
of local
councils the reason I bring I agree with
this amendment is having been on the
standards committee right from the
original concept long before I was
actually uh a District counselor when I
was a parish counselor and I do know and
I do
understand how Parish councils work and
I do feel that unless there's
representation on complaints about
Parish counselors because the committee
will be doing with that that it may be
slightly biased in the wrong wrong
direction hence the reason for my
Amendment thank you
chairman so I've just been advised that
M Council FD was advised that that
suggested amendment was not valid so
afraid we can't put that forward so any
any other
comments do I have okay chairman could I
have a um a reasonless to why not Val
okay Mrs mu thank you chairman um the
council has already agreed the terms of
reference and the membership of
committees at its last meeting uh in
December so the six-month rule applies
to that Amendment so it's not valid
because of that matter um and in
addition it is not possible for a an
independent person appointed by the
council to be a member of a standards
panel because their job is to advise the
panel not to sit on the panel so it's
not possible to uh permit an independent
person to be part of that
decision-making panel thank you chair
okay c m gson sorry Emily can I just
clarify that also applies to Parish
counselors they're not four counselors
are they thank you chair
um the case of parish councilors is that
the council could decide to co-op Parish
members onto various different bodies to
a committee to a working group however
they wouldn't have any voting rights
because they are not members of this
Council all right so do we have a
proposal in a second for this motion
this proposition so Mr and Mrs Mason the
council right so we have a proposition
on the floor and so we'll proceed on
with the vote then the revised rord
District Council cons stitution be
adopted with effect from the 21st of May
2024 all those in
favor thank you members all those
against any abstentions one abstention
then that is carried members so we're
moving on from there then thank
you right now we come to the
oh can I just remind members we've got
20 minutes so I just want to bring that
to your notice so we come to item 13
independent remal panel uh and I'll
invite Emily y to introduce this
report thank you chairman um I'm very
delighted to introduce this report um
which provides members with the details
of the review of allowances undertaken
by the independent remuneration panel um
members I did have a longer introduction
but I'm very mindful of time and I think
the time is best used in debate so I
will just draw your attention to two key
aspects firstly the council must have
regard to the recommendations of the IRP
but it does not have to adopt them
therefore the council may choose to
adopt an alternative proposal and
secondly a councelor may choose not to
receive all or part of any allowance
that they are entitled to by giv uh
written notice to the proper officer
chairman I'm very happy to answer any
questions on the report um and would ask
either for a proposer and seconder for
the recommendations as published or ask
that members move and second an
alternative proposal which will then be
the substantive motion under debate
thank you chairman C
[Music]
W thank you chairman um if I may speak
to the report uh at item 13 when you ask
uh a uh person or a body to conduct an
independent review of something there is
normally a reason why you ask someone to
do an independent review and that is
because it involves member remuneration
and the arrangements
thereof
so personally I have a principle that to
then read the report and start um
putting amendments and doing all sorts
of stuff to it um uh disrespect shall we
say the panel that has put it together
so uh whilst I will look at this report
and not actually make judgment on it
what I will say is play was made in a
member briefing uh a week or so back um
that there has been absolutely no
discussion or engagement with members
and I understand why that statement was
made but I think it's disappointing
because I think uh member engagement
discussion with members um would have
helped inform the report
better uh so you can take that from the
implication that I think there are areas
uh that I would have concerns about so I
think it could have been perhaps a
better report than it is but that's not
making judgment on the overall report
which I acknowledge there's an awful lot
of work that has gone into
it so I am aware that there has been
quite a lot of discussion uh in the last
few days um and uh um I have found that
discussion
interesting but it would go against my
personal principles and that of my group
to start pulling the various parts of
that report apart uh and for personal
reasons or other agendas to make
recommendations so what I am going to do
is actually making a
recommendation to change
R1 and I would like to propose an
amendment to I beg you pardon propose an
amendment to
R2 and I think you'll understand the
point that I making if I say that a
further review of allowances be
undertaken during
2025 one year after the first
anniversary of the implementation of the
committee system to validate that the
level of the allowances are reflective
of the actual workload and
responsibilities of the roles so that's
not a huge change but it is a subtle
change and I think that gives us time to
embed the change in structure within the
authority within the government
structure it gives all of us the
opportunity to understand how we feel
how uh committee chairs others might be
remunerated for the work that they're do
doing the extent of the work so that's
intended to be a constructive Amendment
rather than start picking parts of the
uh report apart uh and making individual
recommendations so uh my proposal is
that we accept r one as written R2 as
I've just read out I'm very happy to
read it out again if members wish and R3
as it's also written so that is my
proposal members and on that basis I
believe we as a group uh would be very
comfortable to accept it and compliment
the independent review panel
remuneration panel for the work that
they've done under your guidance thank
you Mr chairman chairman I was going to
second that counc Mr Mason
second councel Mrs Mason was you going
to Second it or was you GNA say
something can I just remind we now 14
minutes so thank you uh chair yes I was
I seem to have been jumped by my
husband most unusual to have a domestic
in the old ho it
members I see no other hand so I'll have
to
Tori did you council mcferson did you
say um chairman actually um I'm not
speaking on this amendment however I
wasn't aware of this amendment and I
thought the suggestion was by offic in
the briefing session to circulate um any
amendments for consideration prior to
this evening so I've got nothing to say
on this but I have got a separate
amendment that I'd like to put forward
thank you
chairman so you can take that that
Amendment now this one Council M will
now be amending council's proposal so we
have to take your Amendment then Council
[Music]
mcferson I'm not so sure it pays much
relevance now um only as I say I wasn't
aware of this and had hoped it would
have been circulated and could I just um
add in no way would I disrespect the
work of the IRP because um they have
done an outstanding job here um th this
is my Amendment um whilst we must have
regard for the recommendations of the RP
we can with reasoning amend or make
further recommendations as a council it
is clear the IRP have completed needed a
good informed piece of work in relation
to the members allowances however the
IRP will not have the knowledge that
members have of of our role in
detail including how members deal with
the day-to-day support to our
residents we are still in the cost of
living crisis we are still experiencing
cutbacks to Local Government funding
which has impacted our
services with this in mind my
recommendation was the following and
referring to
13.3 the table the basic allowances
remain the same at
£5,000 committee chairman allowances
2500 including the chairman of
development Vice chairman allowances
remain the same at
500 including Vice chair of development
so I wasn't ripping apart the report in
any means I was merely saying that we
stay as we are for some of the roles and
not take the
increases this would be a saving of
then for the allowance in future to be
index linked with any annual increase as
recommended thank you chairman do we
have a second to
that
PR second councelor
Williams who wanted first
counc it counc m Belton first was it
okay counc Mrs Belton
you thank you chair um whilst I
completely understand and hear the
sentiment of councelor McPherson's
motion as Emily pointed out at the
beginning of the introduction any member
of this Council can reject their
allowances they can forfeit their
allowances in part or all of at this
time I don't believe anyone is
forfeiting their allowances and they
they're being claimed I recognize that a
number of people do donate them to
charity and do other good things with
them which is fantastic but the panel
was called the panel have done a piece
of work and if the respon want was have
been if they felt that the amount should
have been dropped I would also have been
supporting that recommendation the fact
that they want to put some of them up
slightly it's academic in my opinion we
asked them to do a piece of work
independently they've done that and I
would like to see us support that and I
I do hear councelor McPherson's um
sentiment and I do believe that some
people may reject the increase if it
goes through but I would like to support
the report and the recommendations with
recommendation two Amendment as as I see
it thank you I'm I really really
important all the time canc M you had
your hand up a while so I'll give you a
chance and then I'm going to go to a
vote on this
so thank you chairman it won't take a
minute um I'm in favor of following the
recommendations of the panel uh and the
reason is the relevant risk SE SE
section on page
13.2 paragraph 4.1 4.2 that the risk is
eventually if we didn't follow this and
it has been extensive
inflation we have a risk of not having a
legally compliant system of allowances
which acts negatively an effect on
enabling a diverse um range of people to
stand as counselors because they don't
always fall into the areas of having um
sort of income support and all that kind
that sort of business so from that point
of view I'm in favor of the
recommendation of the panel is is with
the amendment that we already voted for
thank you right members I'm going to
stop the question there because we need
to get on I've only got a short period
I've got time here now because we didn't
vote forward so on the amendment put
forward by Mrs Mrs mcferson councelor
mcferson all those in
favor two all those
against yeah thank you any
abstentions
so again it's lost members that has been
lost so we come back to the other
Amendment as put by councelor won
seconded by Mrs Belton uh sorry seconded
by Mrs Mason I apologize um was to um if
I could recall the wording those to item
two was said so I'm going to go to item
one because it was in three sections so
I'll have to split this up unfortunately
so if I can go to um all those in favor
of item one the scheme of members
allowances recommended by the
independent reming panel as appendix B
be agreed all those in
favor thank you members close again
one oh sorry
okay any
abstentions three so that item R1 is
carried thank you we come to the the one
that amended item two that a further
review of allowances be undertaken
during 2025 if I've got that correctly
um uh one year after the the um
anniversary would that be
correct U of the committee system to
validate the level allowances are
reflected in the actual workload and
responses of roles do I have that
correct councelor W thank you all those
in
favor thank you all those
against any
extensions then that okay thank you that
is carried item three then the last one
the Council adopts a parental leave
policy for members the content of which
is determined by the council all those
in
favor thank you those
against any
extensions and that motion is carried as
well thank
you we've done 14 15
so
really well item 16 notice on motion
there are
none item 17 report of urgent decisions
there are none item 18 report the leader
work of the executive councelor Mason do
you want to do this or do you want to
adjin us to another meeting no chairman
I'll take it now as long as I can rattle
through uh I'll um I'll I'll concate it
as they say I've consulted with lead
members and the CLT to establish the
reports that are coming to the executive
on the 19th of
March I expect to see the materials
recovery facilities contract report an
update on Energy company obligation eco4
and the Great British insulation uh and
home upgrade Grant
to uh purchase of um waste and street
cleaning Vehicles an update on the
introduction of separate food waste an
update on the Strategic assets program
an update on M Hall and a proposal from
the Leisure contract working group on
the reassessment of In-House provision
couldn't do it any faster thank you
chairman thank
you Cas
Ward yeah thank you chairman can I just
make a request to the leader if he can
make sure that's publicized in the
minutes please what he's what he's
actually said thank
you Mo chairman as I've said before the
member services um group asked me to
submit exactly what I've said and it's
in the minutes thank you very much thank
you very much members I must commend you
on your time keeping it's one minute to
go um save me a little bit of a worri
there thank you very much for this
evening it's been very interesting we
now conclude the meeting at
9:58 thank you
members please be up standing while our
C our chairman councelor laurman and our
chief executive Jonathan Stevenson
retire from our meeting thank you very
much